le comédien fabrice luchini l'animateur
michel drucker où la chanteuse véronique
sanson savez vous quel est leur point
commun est bien tous ont réussi sans le
bac je vais rater à un point et demi ou
deux points et je dois dire que je m'en
tape complètement même décontraction
pour la chanteuse et actrice annie kof
en 1992 elle vivait plutôt bien sa vie
son diplôme je paye mon bac j'ai pas de
vivre et sa maman ça ne m'a pas empêché
de réussir ma vie ma vie sentimentale en
1981 l'ancien président du sénat rené
monory avoue aussi ne pas avoir une pac
seul diplôme à son actif un cap2
mécaniciens qui ne l'avait pas empêché
de gravir les échelons politiques
je crois que la chance est d'avoir une
société très ouverte dans laquelle on
peut se former ou se perfectionner à
tous les âges si certains revendiquent
leur réussite sans le bac d'autres au
contraire en font parfois un complexe
c'était le cas de l'ancien ministre
françois géo je m'en vante pas du tout
contraire quand on sait quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup manqué dans la vie j'en
ai une profonde tristesse
même regret pour l'humoriste raymond
devos il se confie en 1997 sur le
plateau de l'émission thé ou café
il en manque toujours quelque chose
parce que chez d'autres produits date il
ya toujours un trou quelques un avis que
partage est l'animateur michel drucker
en 2008
pour y arriver il avait dû travailler
deux fois plus que les autres c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué de réussir dans
la vie lorsqu'on n'a pas fait d'études
surtout quand on choisit la télévision
donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé depuis
autres autodidacte sans le bac
charles aznavour mais le chanteur
relativisait en 2009
je le regrette d'une certaine manière
mais d'autre part j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer des maîtres des gens qui
m'ont apporté quelque chose plus amer
l'acteur fabrice luchini en 1991 il
disait avoir mal vécu cette pression
autour du bac
je comprenais pas de contact je
comprenais pas ça mais j'étais j'étais
horrifiée gt3 et qu'on peut réussir sans
le bac c'est donc possible mais pour
beaucoup le diplôme reste encore
aujourd'hui un graal à atteindre un
diplôme qu'il vaut mieux avoir pour ne
rien regretter
[Musique]